[Musique]
réussite et longévité à l'entrée des
usines on affiche la couleur
[Musique]
ici six tonnes de fromage sont produits
chaque jour de l'un plus qu'un nom c'est
aujourd'hui une entreprise regroupant
cinq fromagerie ou coopératives sont au
total 130 salariés en moins de 20 ans la
pme familiale a multiplié par sept son
chiffre d'affaires jeudi
principal artisan de ce développement le
pdg philippe de l'un fils cadet de la
famille
merci gt depuis l'âge de 3-4 ans partout
il m'emmenait et je suis né dans l'es3
quatre ans il montait sur des casiers de
l'est pour à mouler des fromages et tout
ça et puis ouais je suis né dedans j'ai
tout fait et puis pendant jeu on a eu
des moments difficiles dans les années
90 2000 à être près du dépôt de bilan
donc on apprend aussi beaucoup on
travaille beaucoup en 1969 au coeur du
village de jd sitôt jacques papac rsa
fromagerie son épouse jacqueline
s'occupe de la comptabilité
leur spécialité est alors les poissons
frais au fil du temps des trois enfants
du couple vont rejoindre l'entreprise
après des années 90 difficile la pme
développe sa gamme autour du brillat
savarin bonne pioche
le succès est au rendez vous en 2014
la fromagerie des ménages dans des
locaux flambant neufs
[Musique]
jacques le patriarche a toujours un
bureau dans l'entreprise à près de 80
ans n'est pas peu fier de son petit
empire sous sol
certaines personnes certains collègues
disent rôles de 50 ans après l'accord
allait toujours là nous sommes venus
celles restées là
christine la fille aînée travaille
toujours à la fromagerie pour elle pas
de doute la clé de leur développement
c'est le tandem formé par son père et
son frère philippe
à eux deux ils sont trouvés produits
pour relancer la fromagerie depuis un an
depuis 2000 c'était le brillat savarin
peu de personnes nizet sur ce fromage là
et eux ont réussi à en faire un produit
d'excellence brillat savarin
traditionnels ou fourrées à la truffe ou
encore enrobé de baie la formule séduit
notamment à l'étranger
mais pour l'expédition il a fallu
innover on a créé justement ces cochons
pour c'est ça qui nous a fait fortement
développé dans les années 2000 le grand
export parce que le fromage il s'affine
justement dans le bateau pour arriver
affiné au canada etats unis
la fromagerie réalise 40% de son chiffre
d'affaires à l'export
ces premiers marchés les états unis et
le canada
le pouzin d'outre-atlantique leur achète
pas moins de 100 tonnes de fromage par
an
énormément affecté par les canadiens il
n'y a rien de similaire son marché plus
des gens à bien tout ce qui est
extrêmement que celle est déjà en vente
à l'international croissance porte une
entreprise dynamique tout comme la
nouvelle génération de de l'ain aurélien
et pierre les petits-fils du fondateur
se prépare à prendre le relais j'aime
bien à venir ici travailler à la
fromagerie puis à porter quand même on
est de connaître un peu le projet kong
et pourquoi pas par la suite
oui récupérer la sphère familiale après
je sais que sa pratique chose de facile
et qu'il faut beaucoup de travail mais
je me sens prêt à relever le défi
prochain défi pour les deux l'un doubler
la capacité de production de l'usiné de
gigny un projet parmi d'autres un
chapitre de plus dans l'histoire de
l'entreprise familiale